FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTORS ARI
FLEISCHER AND RAYMOND ARROYO.
AFTER WATCHING THIS TONIGHT, I
HAVE TO CONCLUDE THAT TODAY WAS
A BAD DAY FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
WHY?
NEW POLLS SHOWING THE RACE IS
TIGHTENING IN THE BATTLEGROUND
STATES WHICH MEANS HE THEY
HAVEN’T GOTTEN ANY BOUNCE FROM
THEIR CONVENTION.
THEY FINALLY STARTED TO REALIZE
THAT RIOTS AND LOOTING IS
HURTING THEM POLITICALLY..
SO THEY WERE FORCED TO ROLL OUT
OLD JOE WITH A STATEMENT
CONDEMNING THE VIOLENCE THAT HAS
BEEN ROILING BUT CITIES FOR
MONTHS.
TONIGHT THE REPUBLICANS HAD MORE
BAD NEWS.
OVER AND OVER, REPUBLICAN
SPEAKERS HIT THEMES AND ISSUES
THAT WERE IGNORED LAST WEEK AT
THE DNC.
A CHINESE ACTIVIST WARNED ABOUT
THE DANGERS OF THE CCP.
A MILLENNIAL CANDIDATE FOR
CONGRESS TALKED ABOUT HOW THE
GOP IS THE PARTY OF ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY ONLY 25 YEARS OLD.
FOR THE THIRD NIGHT IN A ROW, A
LINE-UP OF ELOQUENT AFRICAN
AMERICAN SPEAKERS REBUTTED THE
LIE THAT AMERICA IS A RACIST
COUNTRY.
I’MEMPHASISED THE LONG HISTORY O
SUPPORT FOR CIVIL RIGHTS.
IN SHORT, ANOTHER NIGHT OF